[Musique]
a déjà mis de la vie si tous kankan est
astucieux belle
c'est le plus sérieux ça me va vite à
jouer il suffit de vouloir devenir un
ami
il n'y a pas la dernière notin comment
je tiens pour l'ania pas la dernière
note que je tiens très bien la dernière
regarde loin de là visage figé ah non
ainsi telle devise est le visage pur
moment j'aimerais j'aimerais qu'ils me
le rendre un peu plus mobile que sa voix
qui grimace pour commencer vous dire
mais j'ai plus de grimaces moi je ne
sais plus et se situe à large des
grimaces oui je lâche des grimaces
je te fais le bib au jour d'abord
bonjour bonsoir l'harmattan vite la
grimace la grimace je vais le lap a
peut-être je pense que ça va pas être
terrible on va essayer de la part ou au
nom il ya eu plus drôle en par une messe
populaire ferme
je veux faire un truc si tu veux avec
les doigts oui oui parce qu'un petit
exercice l'exercice est arrivé à séparer
tu vois entre l'annulaire est le médium
qui sépare très vite hop comme ça tu
sais faire ça toi et moi j'y prêterais
buteur je sais faire ça ça très vite
moi je peux bien ça y est alors plus
fort encore je vais séparément poussant
de alors ça ça alors ça ce trading vous
voyez oui vous voyez mon pouce là est ce
que vous voyez mon pouce au regard des
monts pousse à vous le voyez vous pose
attention 1 2 3 op c'est pas moi je le
ferai plus cette extraordinaire et au
nord de damas moi je vais t'étonner à
mon tour oui tu vois ses dessins la rive
vois tu le reconnais oui juin
bon oui alors il faut les mettre dans
l'ordre on va je vais t'en faire passer
trois oui mais dans un ordre différent
et yannick histoire en somme ya des ya
des éléments qui se suivent faut
remettre les dessins dans l'ordre qui
m'a compris voilà alors là bon ils sont
trois ils sont chez eux
oui d'accord est l'une des prêtres
prendre le dessin suivants ont bossé il
ya plus de personnages la jeune fille et
un petit chat aussi là tu vois un châle
a toujours un chat dans louis saint tite
a remarqué réveillant j'ai le grand il
aime les adore les qui a bien raison moi
aussi j'adore les chats attend une
troisième un troisième des cinq
troisième scène au bras alors là je
crois que c'est assez facile hein
franchement je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez mais à mon avis il ya une action
qui est en train de se faire dans ces
trois dessins si nous prenions l'action
au départ
prendrait le dessin tient celui là parce
que là il me semble que la dame qui est
au centre de la scène est en train de
tricoter et nous fait une petite
chaussette regarde la chose at elle
n'est pas bien grand oui puis si tu
prends ce dessin là tu as une chaussette
qui est déjà nettement plus grande
ça avance ce travail et puis alors
ensuite nous avions marqué une
chaussette déjà beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup plus longue
alors j'ai l'impression c'est dans cet
ordre là qu'il faut remettre c'est ça
c'est ça le icc ça ça aurait pu l'être
oui mais tout ça elle aurait pu la
défaire mais enfin ils vont enfin comme
elle l'a fait ça alors je m'en vais un
je m'en vais je vais dans le dans le
jardin oui c'est à toi de préparer le
jeu suivant tu nous as tu un derrière la
toile fait tâche et déjà la tâche d'être
à la hauteur l'instant là moi je vais
rejoindre mes amis je vais me tourner
j'y vais en tournage en est la tête qui
vacille à malabo quand même à bonjour
matip est belle on se bouscule ça va
c'est ouvert trop tard
limoux si on appelle bris face à brice
assez malin mais c'est quoi la far hills
puisque c'est comme ça je m'en vais vous
confondre j'avais trouvé la solution
extrêmement rapidement la solution du
point commun ne peut pas nous confondre
m on est vraiment très différents les
uns des autres ça fait de l'esprit tout
quand je vais voir ailleurs
le point commun est pris oui je le sais
quand le point commun c'est en quelque
sorte un point à découvrir entre vous
car vous serez différentes choses je
suppose et il faut que vous même et moi
nous arrivions à nous sortir de cette
affaire là en découvrant le point qui
vous unit tous les trois voilà nous
allons gagner alors fabrice je suis une
montre
ça ne m'étonne pas moi une grosse montre
pas une petite monte ridicule sur
lesquels on a du mal à lire l'heure
non non je suis une de ces belles
montres ronde que les hommes mettent ou
plutôt mettait d'ailleurs d'aaland dans
la poche de leur gilet je regrette bien
d'ailleurs que ça se fasse de moins en
moins ça revient en fanfare vient tout
passe un bon alors une montre qu'on sort
fièrement qu'on tient solidement dans le
creux de sa main une autre qu'on porte à
son oreille pour vérifier qu'elles
marchent bien
oui oreilles mais fier que l'oreille
marche bien une demande qui ne faut pas
oublier de remonter tu vois et elle peut
être en aurait peut être en acier le
peut être en argent guimauve peu importe
je me souviens d'ailleurs que mon grand
père qui en avait une comme ça on était
très content oui ça me fait rire abord
qu elle seule les airs mon grand père
était complètement sonné et quiz pour
disait dans le 400m doivent tenter
quelque chose on veut pas dire 500
ampères seniors
oui c'est un monsieur pour moi
aujourd'hui je suis très impressionnante
quand on me regarde de loi on ne peut
d'ailleurs me regarder que de loin on
est frappé par mon aspect majestueux
je suis un de ces massifs montagneux
dans les sommets couvert de neige se
confondent avec le ciel tu peux
m'appeler les pyrénées ou les alpes le
caucase ou même la cordillère des andes
fabrice c'est à dire qu'on me trouve
dans toutes les parties du monde
il ya chez moi d'école des pics de
glaciers des vallées on se sert de moi
pour faire de merveilleuses cartes
postales qui est fabrice si tu trouves
jetten enverrai une vue
oui et ça me paraît intéressant ça bêle
bêle sympa intéressant j'attends une
confirmation de pouce moussu et je vous
donnerai la solution car tous nos amis
en sont au même point que moi il hérite
déjà de la facilité avec laquelle ils
vont le découvrir au yen à la solution
corps je la donnerai à la news
lorsque chris eu mort a expliqué ce qui
lève à moi moi je dois être franc avec
toi vu j'ai fait une très très grosse
bêtise je ne sais pas ce qui m'a pris je
je n'ose même pas de raconter j'ai
changé j'ai honte j'ai honte
enfin le résultat est là malheureusement
je je suis en prison
oui je suis un prisonnier mon ami dans
un cachot humide et froid avec une toute
petite fenêtre un peu plein de barreaux
on a peur que je mets van an c'est très
désagréable la nuit j'ai souvent
l'impression que j'entends courir des
rats et et tu sais un tu sais que tu
sais pas le pire mais on a mis un boulet
au pied levé je peux pas me promener
comme les autres c'est très désagréable
voilà qu'au départ moi j'avais bien
trouver un lien entre tous cancan qui
était une aiguille une je pense à
l'aiguillé alors l'éguille ça va pas
avec lui dis moi encore une aiguille
entre vous de savoir avec lui je vois
pas où l aiguille
apprends d'aiguilhe voyons ya pas d
ennemis qu'il est un prisonnier en
répétant chaîne me boulay chacun leurs
aînés sa mise en scène
alors est ce que c'est parce que là j'ai
pas trop bas la chaîne mais je voyais
pas ce ne sera pas cette fois ci à
limoges et bien oui quel continent sur
nous et sur nos lauriers faute à moi à
part et mes petites notes musicales
tu fais un gros bisou mon beauf qui tout
comme fabrice content on va jouer tous
les deux maintenant oui bah oui je
change à chercher mon stylo bien entendu
le choix idéal toujours pas encore
oublié ton style oh oui bah oui bon
parce que celle ci est oui cette fois ci
chez pas trop difficile va chez un tout
petit mot à mot ans il est ancien oui
comment sortir ça commence par un n 1 et
meilleur alors tu fais quatre petits
prêts oui voilà
mais à bien y la dernière lettre et la
dernière lettre c'est un ace
voila voila voila je crois que tu vas
trouver tout de suite
rui un oiseau oh non pas qu'une plante
non pas une plante un animal non plus
une fleur non plus ah qu'est-ce qui
reste un homme non non non une femme non
non un enfant non écoute alors là la
troisième c'est pas l'animal non je ne
serai pas une fois c'est pas une plante
non qu'est ce qui peut bien tu veux la
troisième l'est puis dit toujours la
troisième lettre c'est un v1 v avait
instruit
non c'est pas tout à un arbre non plus
au parc à prier bien rester on est là
une semaine un insecte
non non plus non je suis pas en forme
aujourd'hui boussu du lait je vais
t'aider va c'est un légume un lieu
alors là ça si c'est un légume g unit
l'unité tout de suite là c'est un légume
un peu blanc non oui oui un peu long à
trouver
c'est ce qui est tombée quand j'ai
encore fait est ce que tu te serais pas
tromper aujourd'hui ce que pour la
première fois depuis le début de ce jeu
tu meures est écrit correctement ce à
quoi je pense c'est pâques à quoi à quoi
penses tu pas un navet bah oui un navet
ban avait ça s'écrit comment ben avait à
un ace
abbas que c'est comme ça que tu écris
n'avait avidar je me disais aussi
illusion n'a pas bon a parce que ça
marchait sur le nombre de lettres
heureusement ça ne s'écrit pas tout à
fait comme ça à rabat nous voilà
rassurés nous retrouvons notre pouce
moussu donner un moment d'espérance mais
20,1 avait à la limite ça s'écrirait
plutôt comme ça en français voient un
avait eu tes afin dé n'avait eu tsa
voilà comment ça j'ai pas de chance et
quand je pense que j'ai eu la bêtise
d'imaginer que tu avais écrit
correctement
moi je savais pas que tu n'avais pas ma
femme est ce que c'est ce que je sais
c'est ainsi que le navet c'est pas
seulement un légume un con mais dans le
pot-au-feu vous avec lesquels les gens
très gourmand là comme toi par exemple
au fond du canard aux navets il ya
quelqu'un qui aime le n'avait encore
plus que toi ce sont les abeilles
oui parce que la fleur du navet elle est
très sucré et les abeilles elles en font
un miel excellent jeu s'avère ainsi à
excellent bon bah maintenant faudrait
que tu ailles voir un je suis allé au
terme de la verdure la preview j'habite
à oui oui oui c'est une caisse de tes
seins c'est bien avec abbas oui ça
arrive à ça c'est abusé mais allons voir
belle belle belle belle fête avec
la twa fabrice bien jouer avec moi là
c'est facile la musique tibétains dans
cette salle la cen sad en très bon état
d'esprit de compléter mes phrases avec
des notes de la gamme c'est moi qui vais
compléter tes notes de la gamme avec des
phrases mais alors on commence tout de
suite parce que on va prendre un exemple
oui alors tu place une note sur la
portée musicale alors si tu le veux bien
puis j'avais préparé ma portée musicale
parce que tout en tout cas comme avait
dit oui aujourd'hui bel bel va essayer
de t'avoir et nous allons jouer à
l'envers ou alors j'ai elle vient j'ai
placé toutes mes notes sur la porte et
oui et lorsque je te désignerait une
note
tu auras la gentillesse de bien vouloir
compléter ce que je vais te dis d'accord
ce pas alors suis moins bien parce que
je vais improviser
alors attention on vit alors première
note celle ci tous nos amis connaissent
lorsque l'été il fait très beau je suis
sur la plage et je suis allongé sur le
sur le coin sur le ca sur le sur le
sable enfin regarde les nommer qu'est ce
que c'est 10 à l'élan sur le sol sur le
sol
tu te dire aussi sous un parasol
surtout si tu veux mes vacances je suis
bien débrouillée quand même mais tu
m'aimes tu peux affole les ventes
l'habitude six nations et les questions
du oui mais maintenant c'est le
contraire
dans la vie on se fait des arts des amis
des amis très bien bon parfois lorsqu'il
fait très chaud on se passe de l'huile
solaire sur le don sur le dos parfait
sur le dos oui m je m'appelle boom brice
bon de brice baume brice fabrice fabrice
s est très très bien servi à oppama
lorsque kelis lorsque quelqu'un te dis
par exemple tu t'es trompé non je ne me
suis pas trompé ils te répondent ici
si affirmatif si tu t'es trompé très
bien piloté
me tromper et ben ça veut dire que si je
veux aider enchante
tu veux qu'on chante maintenant oui je
tricotais si tu as peur de se tromper
oui ça coûte ses longues et tous les cas
c'est déjà pas une amie d'état qui fait
que la vie majeur s'est désisté et
rzeszow des choses mais comme je n'ai
pas de mine war l'aideront à faire
attention les cartes à ne pas descendre
et 10 des cats a mis son de retard il
est l'ami
oui
[Musique]
mais j'invite pas jouer entre lui et la
famille vouloir devenir amis
je maniago chapeau dans l'oeil
[Musique]